people are obsessed with crime they
really are I mean you look at the show
for instance killer instinct that is on
investigation discovery the ID Network
and that network literally has either
the first or second number of female
viewers from that coveted demographic
yeah not just of cable but in all of
broadcast right and people watch because
it went in because females are those are
the ones most likely to be like shopping
and spending money with advertising
right well I taken care of Heinz it's a
part of it we also get a very healthy
you know male viewership on you know the
various crime shows that I do I think
what draws people in is this attitude
that I try to bring to every show where
you know I take the viewer long on a
journey of discovery we get to see
things they wouldn't normally see here
things they wouldn't normally hear yeah
you know I get to go places mm-hmm that
most people don't get to go I get to
talk to people yes people don't get to
talk to you and so that's fascinating
for the average viewer right going back
to talking about how women watch a lot
of those types of shows do you feel like
there's something secretive in women or
something that like I've always had this
weird idea that some women like want to
be murdered in a weird way and I know
that's kind of a drastic statement but
like there's something about it what is
that well you know that's that's a great
question and I think it's it's a lot of
things I think that you know women
empathize with victims men do to Ryan
get a lot of you know grizzled male cops
who watch these shows all the time and
wall street guys and business people and
you know audience 80km and but I but I
do think that for whatever reason again
our key demographic on a lot of these
shows excuse female do you think killers
seemed like tall dark and handsome in a
way to women like is there is there like
on it like a different level do you feel
like there's some romantic thing cuz
yeah for some reason in my head I'm like
women secretly all want to have someone
break into their home or something I
don't buy that I think it's it's more of
or I'm gonna learn how this
happen so I don't become a villain snuff
and that's kind of the way I look at
these shows these investigations it is
if we can hear the voice of a victim
victim's family if we can get into the
mind of a criminal whether it's a killer
or a predator you know sex trafficker or
human trafficker or somebody dealing
heroin and in Dayton Ohio mm-hmm you can
better understand how it all works and
you can prevent other people from
falling into that trap of becoming a
victim themselves and that's a big part
of what I do yeah good evening good
afternoon and other times thanks for
watching that video you just saw I mean
it was okay but the next video you can
watch could be way better what if you
watch a video right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one watch this one watch
this one watches one